hi there reject nation I'm Greg album
Alabama seer I'm John Humphrey we all
love Game of Thrones we wanted to watch
it together winters here we have our
camera plugged into streaming from our
laptop that way we could just do this
all in one take because you know we
don't have to worry about the camera
cutting every 30 minutes
Olivia has read all the Game of Thrones
books so I figured it would be best if
we had someone who's more of an expert
than John and I here what are you
talking about a couple of things I
wanted to mention right up front first
off YouTube only allows for at least 10
minutes of footage to be shown for the
YouTube video reactions last year when
we or two years ago we did like part 1
part 2 like pretty much divided it up we
got into some copyright issues and a few
of those videos got blocked so this one
episode every episode for season 8 it's
only gonna be 10 minutes worth of the
reaction but the full-length TV show
reaction stream alongs you can go to our
patreon page head over there we have
plenty of shows where we do a reaction
watch alongs and we also have several
shows that reaction highlights included
and a bunch of other goodies and last
thing I wanted to mention the person
who's gonna be editing this for us
because there's a bunch of boxes behind
us we're in the middle of moving so we
need to hire an editor we hired our good
friend Eric over at nerd cronic this guy
edits for several people including Eamon
snow aqus on the Schmo down he's worked
there as well
it's just a very very friendly guy you
could check out his YouTube videos his
podcast anywhere you could really find
podcast it's a really wonderful dude and
so thank you Eric so much for helping us
edit video follow him at nerd cronic
anyway enough in short time let's get to
the main event Peter Dinklage is top
billing
yeah cuz everyone loved
[Music]
they're related I know about it oh we're
gonna get there you didn't notice her
yes look for he's a badass yeah cuz he's
gonna keep that strong [ __ ] up Wow
Oh re I really scared but she's like my
my look I love town mom daddy I love it
oh he's he's almost did you lose your
balls too cuz we got two in the group as
beautiful as your brother claimed Wow he
just dropped them great how are you
doing I had a choice keep my crown I'll
protect the law
I chose not
some leadership right there and soon the
last the army will be right North to
join apples
I would you bet to them anyway people
whatever they want okay well that is not
good this is the season's gonna be like
the Avengers but if every adventure was
like a whole bunch of people will they
or won't they get along with his new
girl in the trailers cool how did you
see you got me how do you survive and I
see that
yeah it's only been how long like a week
yeah
is this several years she's using more
than that
yeah don't downplay accomplishments like
a serial killer at this boy thank you
thank you Jesus it's like he's possessed
by a magical vagina I don't understand
who's saying he's like supremely whipped
yes he's like it's like what happens
every time someone sleeps with Danny
it's insane she does seem to have some
kind of glamor power over
I can and she has a magical cookies
she's okay with that
muddy shots I just want to see their
budget this season pretty much all of
your shoot copies of their accounting
it's really impressive how everyone
looks exactly like how they did two
years production yes that's why she's
gonna die
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know please the Queen you might be
yes yes oh she's so smart
yeah he's gonna think oh that's clever
she is so that is clever you did that to
me when we first started dating I'm
gonna shout shout all the Circe's baby
theorists she just started to tear up
their hell yeah
and you headbutt her okay that's their
secret hit you want to come to penny I
know you wanted me to them to fight for
the stocks
Oh Theon you had a really hard life
buddy he's he's brought some of that
upon himself but he's awesome I mean he
betrayed the stars to be supper hmm
she's good at reading she doesn't need
to be friends oh my god you're such a
[ __ ] fear me she can't respect me what
you gonna do she's know you to be able
to respect you
dragons trying to be like you returned
Aryan man oh my god
come on hiccup oh [ __ ] you don't ride
the dragon he's gonna ride the dragon
they're gonna do it on top of the
Dragons whoa we're gonna go how do you
not know Jackie it was a gift from
timber
[Music]
we all know they're gonna have like a
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
really still love like I can't show that
is exactly how they were reunited
Salieri's do I always knew you were just
another rich girl
ah was the diester I mean you wouldn't
worry about who holds what title I'm
telling you it doesn't matter without we
don't stand a chance
do you have any faith in me at all no I
don't but you know it dude it's totally
right she should know related there and
I am either if it's true I could use a
palm oh she just realized big dick I
just killed your whole family yeah I've
smelled his burning flesh
I only did it to retain his integrity oh
yeah oh my God why did tact bit test
Jesus Christ
oh hey John's gonna be like you guys
she's not that bad
she's whole the worst look at her old
buddy no
[Music]
[Laughter]
No yes oh okay
bust this Aegon Targaryen truly behind
you
oh my truth you gave him your crowns as
a few people there we have more gas
gonna bang her one more time for it
tells course Oh No yeah not where are
they they're on mr. New Castle block the
lights in this apartment very kind of
had a little bitty it's over the vision
I know I can't see that the banners here
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is less
[Music]
- Monday you guys Richard break Jamie oh
damn oh [ __ ] remember remember when you
closed
[Music]
[Laughter]
talk about it well guys what you think
of the episode I mean I'm still a little
you know putting myself together I'm
still a little speechless from the
excitement of everything and seeing
everybody coming back together seeing
just the setup of all the stakes and I
think you know the elephant in the room
of like holy [ __ ] they just came out and
told him you know yeah I mean it's it is
similar to how I remember one last the
last season came around people were like
yeah the first episode was kind of like
it's cool you know wasn't anything super
exciting but that's what they do the
first episodes they're setting you up
so maybe the crazy exciting stuff that
hasn't happened yet with all the big
battles we heard they're gonna be in
this episode or you know any of that
crazy amount of budget we heard that is
gonna be infused in here
it's all like it's been a couple years
even though there's been a lot of recaps
and stuff it's reintroduction you know
you get a few cool reunions that I liked
Arya and the Hound I thought was pretty
neat yeah some stuff I thought they kind
of wrapped up a little quicker than I
expected and then I cliffhanger with
Theon gonna go rescue sister Yara and I
think that's her name and then they like
wrap that up really quickly yeah he goes
rescue her and then we're heading out
there and it's cool we're Theon's
adventures going to next
oh yeah gonna back up the Starks yeah I
want to make good on past transgressions
this episode was just a lot of like
quick quick catch ups Creek catch ups
all around with a lot of Winterfell
focus and you know and Daenerys and Jon
I you guys you didn't really seem to be
liking it I thought it was cool that he
was riding the Dragons but then you do
bring up a good point of how has no one
really put this together yet was a good
episode I think it's a good episode when
it doesn't end with you know it's good
up so when John finding out who he is
isn't the end yeah you know so I thought
it was good upset I think it was very
Harry Potter ish with at the beginning
of every Harry Potter movie they're all
like we're back at Hogwarts yeah yeah
and so I felt like it was very much that
but it makes sense for what it is but
yeah I liked it I thought it was good I
just don't like Danny and John together
so I'm very anti incest maybe that's
maybe maybe about it is about it maybe
they'll make the relationship even
stronger now guess think about I don't
think how does the incest but yeah it
just makes it stronger are they turned
off by incest in this I know say this
world are the are they world the
targaryen normal everyone I don't care
it's not normal for us even for like
Jamie and Cersei
maybe it's normal for you people but not
it's not normal for us people watching
it so well I shouldn't be rooting for it
would Jaime and Cersei people everyone
seems to know about it and no one's like
I can't believe you did that brother
yeah it's taboo but still it's like
don't know everyone's like yeah you know
it's like we shouldn't talk about it but
whatever that's kind of the attitude is
because they were like she was gonna
tell us what you know difference I guess
is that people do look down upon like
Jaime and Cersei getting together
because they're directly brother and
sister that's like one degree separation
I feel like people get chiller in this
society anyway of the show the further
out in your family that you get so like
people wouldn't find out that Daenerys
is John's and be like and well you know
what not I don't think to the same
degree worth like gosh this is your
brother dude like the the tease that
they have with was the line that Sam
said about you know that how he would
sacrifice his position as king but
when Daenerys sacrificed her position as
queen gonna be the biggest obstacle more
yeah there really and I didn't even
think about that but a lot of the things
that sort of how Emilia Clarke sort of
gets criticized for her portrayal of
Daenerys of not being too much of an
emotional character yes I know she'd the
dragon but I was kind of wondering if
that's gonna factor in though to this
this show which you know like they had
that whole thing with her killing Sam's
parents Sam's dad and Sam's brother and
how she didn't seem to she was just kind
of you know very stoic about the whole
thing like a very slight hint of guilt
if even that so thanks a lot for doing
me a huge favor and it seems like even
though Johnson it seems like even though
Jon Snow it's a lot of people in the
North are opposed against this whole
situation if they find out who Jon Snow
really is I feel like they're all gonna
want Jon Snow to really be the king as
they would and what kind of conflict is
that gonna create for not just between
Jon Snow and Daenerys but Daenerys and
everyone here you know yeah because I'm
kind of wondering where where this is
all I didn't think about that dark path
that it could lead down yeah would not
just like oh we're gonna have to talk
this out but Daenerys can get very
violent in the way she reacts with that
Targaryen blood that she has you know
yeah yeah she's quick to displays of
power sometimes where she out maybe not
to but it's like I could see Jon Snow
not wanting to kill the nerves but I
could see Daenerys being like [ __ ] the
head I'm gonna kill Jon exactly yeah
this is now a threat to her being Queen
because he is the rightful heir to the
throne so that's that's ultimately gonna
be the bigger obstacle which it really
shouldn't be because you know incest but
yeah
be interesting to see how that plays out
I also think it's funny that they ended
with bran and Jamie because Fran's not
gonna do anything he's gonna have no
reaction he's a three-eyed Raven now
he's gonna feel like he's gonna go up to
it bubbles some stuff like you will die
in three days or something like that
it's to be so freely [ __ ] and Jamie's
gonna be like all nervous and he's gonna
oh you don't care okay good the way this
show edited that ending moment edited it
as if it was a cliffhanger well it's not
really a I don't think it's a real
cliffhanger I think it's just a final
note of the last of the reunions you
know what I mean when did that cuz that
happens in the first episode of the
first season okay so in that way I guess
that's how it made sense to me was like
oh okay so they're like Buch ending it
if like the very end of everything ends
with them yeah nice to face it it's sort
of captured in a way like clipping or
what's gonna happen but I don't think
anything's gonna happen from it it's not
gonna braid doesn't care brands change
and Jamie's changed so much since that
moment you know well I think it's a way
for them but it's like maybe in a way
both of them shouldn't be here or
something and it's a way that like after
so long for the show to kind of
acknowledge the longevity and to harken
back to a moment from you know the very
first episode or something like that's
like yeah I don't feel like it does a
lot of thrust to the story but it's just
a motif to end this return upon you know
I wish we got some moments would like
Brienne or or Podrick yeah it'll be nice
to get a little bit of they see them in
the background showed up for they issued
loose to a close-up on them and have an
exchange won't mind a dialogue so we can
know how they're doing well this this
seems to be sort of reflective of how
far we've come since season one because
you do get that opening shot even though
I know they're all in Winterfell it's
the whole point it did semi remind me of
how the very opening shot the very
opening scene of the first episode of
this whole series took place in the
wintertime you know when they see that
first white Walker and then it and then
the end the way that episode ends is
with Jaime pushing bran out the window
and then he this episode ends with them
re-- you not I like them seeing each
other again since since that moment you
know
and I truly I truly love how they have
re and Santa sticking by each other's
side yeah that makes the most sense to
me and it doesn't make sense to me that
John does not see where Santa's coming
from or Arya when the outsiders have
been the biggest threat to the Starks
the entire show right so of course it
makes sense that another outsider comes
in and saw just like what the hell yeah
of course it makes sense so Don going in
and be like why aren't you being nice to
my girlfriend like it's baffling to me
and kind of talking down to sons instead
of talking through it or understanding
where she's coming from frustrates me a
little bit and that's where I get more
frustrated at the Danny and John dynamic
and I feel it's more forced well I feel
like everyone's so emotional at this
because Jon Snow's has had everyone
always up against him for pretty much
every major choice he's ever had exactly
that's why they're all emotional about
the whole thing yeah for everybody cuz
cuz he has had such a tenuous
relationship with like literally
everyone and it's like there were
mutinies and things and like there's a
lot coming you know king of the north
and all that stuff so like i imagine
yeah like even one slip like this is
enough to kind of make everybody woozy
about Jon Snow again and I don't know I
feel like maybe if the personal scenes
between John and Danny were I don't know
something different it could back up cuz
like I understand John the point like we
gotta check the north leg I brought you
back like weapons and [ __ ] we have
dragons now this point without with the
dead I risk my life to bring back at one
point but I also get Saunders point of
why don't you understand where
everyone's caught yeah it's a big gray
area yeah you know it's not black don't
like John has a great point that it
doesn't matter who's leader when when
the [ __ ] debtor coming our way you
vote matters as we can all survive and
that's what he cares first and foremost
about but you still gotta connect with
the people on their level yeah exactly
because that's what's got him
decision-making before without bringing
it to the people so what was happening
with the little boy tied up and all in
the way the shapeless dough it's the
white Walker design so we're the first
white Walker was killed the kid little
I'm not sure what the tie-in to the
little kids and the white walkers cuz
that's how the first white Walker was
made the night king was that was the
symbol that was made and in the first
episode oh okay design so that's how
that design is made here as well it's in
the shape of Tobin white Walker design
gotcha just with that little boy who who
he know was and that was he came into
the ha'la'tha yeah and this is the first
episode when you see that sign you see
that sign in the first episode and then
you find out how the night king was made
yeah yeah yeah I remember that episode
that moment yeah with those alien
looking creatures yeah like that's
awesome
yeah so at first I thought it was the
Targaryen symbol but it's not it's a
white Walker I was like is that it is
kind of interesting
funny how we didn't really have him
because you're right she did get over
her dragon death pretty quick like
there's gonna be there's gonna be no
concern over the stake of the situation
of they have their own dragon now yeah
we have two dragons but they have one
and they have a whole army of the undead
it's like there's some serious odds
serious odds and now how are we going to
defeat an undead dragon exactly yeah
there is no conversation about that
there's no conversation about how are
her dragons going to feel going up
against all these episodes nearly 90
minutes that's something we only have 5
episodes left there's 8 episodes 6 or 7
right there's only there's only 6 so
like we're only a 5 episode look this is
gonna be like chaos Matt it's like oh
yeah I mean like I I really did like
this episode of course is exciting cuz
it's the first time Game of Thrones has
come back this seemed to lean a little
bit more into the soap opera side of
Game of Thrones instead of like the cool
political debate side of Game of Thrones
which I thought we were gonna get more
of I think we get more of that with
Cersei which is why I do love more of
this
see see insist because you do get the
political undertone yeah she's actually
leading like yeah even even the moment
that see my eighty even though it's
really gonna be soap opera when she's
like when she after she has sex with uh
you're on your andre job did you find
out oh wait there was another kind of
plan here she's already pregnant right
she's pregnant that's Jamie's baby oh
that's so smart I put a little prince to
your like damn she's clever we also have
to realize that that prophecy that none
of her children will live so with what's
going to happen to that baby I thought
it was a reference to this specific
three that already died no it says that
she will never have like like all of her
kids right the prophecy was that was a
matter so she's gonna die this season
anyway there is a popular theory on the
internet that Circe's baby is dead and
that Cersei is you know a known fibber
so like and there and I will say that
through that lens at the very end of the
shot when Euron leaves the room and you
can see like the gears turning she does
look like she's like tearing up at the
end like something she even really
pregnant what Jamie's baby I wonder and
now she's pregnant and that's why she
was smiling my theory is that she thinks
she's not pregnant and and that she
secretly is but she thinks she's lying
to everybody about being praised she's
gonna be the most surprised when she is
alright guys well what theories do you
have that are speculating now from
watching this episode of Game of Thrones
hopefully this video is least up on
YouTube might not be monitor it at least
up on YouTube
well you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell thanks Olive Branch for being here
follow her at forever Tiffany's you'll
find photos of her and I on there and
cats
great now I'm your male gigolo babes no
deuce Greg on the hook oh yeah that
makes you stop we're out roaming this
and patreon tree on that's right the
full-length TV show reaction
is over at our patreon page so go there
right away please
if you want to watch along with us
because Eric I'm sure you had a great
time cutting this down since we talk so
much thanks to thank you so much nerd
tronic please he go follow him on
Twitter go check out his YouTube videos
and podcasts links in the description
box we'll see you guys next week in more
videos throughout the week on the real
rejects peace at peace